من الجانب الاوكراني هناك اعتراف بصعوبه
الوضع في منطقه باخمد و داخل المدينه
والحديث عن ما يحدث هناك دانه دائما ما
تصفه السلطات الاوكرانيه
يعني الامر المرعب ويعني حتى البعض يتحدث
عن يعني
مساله انسانيه صعبه جدا الاوضاع خطيره
لدرجه ان ربما باتت القوات الاوكرانيه
تفكر بسحب مقاتليها من هناك حفاظا على
ارواح المقاتلين خاصه وعلى ما يبدو فان
القوات الروسيه وخاصه مجموعه
من ثلاثه اتجاهات اي ان من الناحيه
العمليه عسكريا الذي ليس هناك جدوى من
المقاومه خاصه وان ثلاثه محاور تم السيطره
عليها بشكل تام هناك محور فقط في الجانب
الغربي من منطقه بخموت والذي
[موسيقى]
وهي تله يمكن ان تستخدمها القوات
الاوكرانيه كخط مرتفع لتوجيه ضربات لداخل
محمود فيما اذا يعني انسحبت من كامل من
هذه القوات اذا اوضاع صعبه تعترف القوات
الاوكرانيه بصعوبه الموقف لكنها لحد هذه
اللحظه لم تعترض بالسيطره الكامله للقوات
الروسيه على هذه المنطقه هناك مقاومه
مستمره على ما يبدو لكن هذه المقاومه ليست
باي ثمن على حد تعبير المسؤولين
الاوكرانيين اذا مقاومه لحد هذه اللحظه لا
يجب الاستناد فقط عن يعني
المعلومات الروسيه في هذه يعني الاونه او
في هذه المرحله من الحرب يجب ان يعني ان
نحذر لانها قد تكون ايضا من باب الحرب
النفسيه التي تاخذها القوات الروسيه التي
تحاصر هذه المنطقه
رفيق منذ اكثر من سبعه اشهر وهي
حرب طويله وبطيئه لكنها حرب باسلحه ثقيله
وايضا هناك مصاعب جديده اضيفت بعد يعني
التغيرات المناخيه الذوبان جليد بسبب
ارتفاع درجات الحراره في المنطقه الحاليه
تسبب بتحويل المنطقه الى منطقه طينيه يصعب
للمقاتلين الاوكرانيين وكذلك المعدات
الاوكرانيه القديمه
العائده الى العهد السوفيتي بان تقاوم
فيها كذا ظروف وان تتقدم لذلك اصبحت يعني
هدف ثابت وسهل للقوات الاوكرانيه التي
تمكنت على ما يبدو من احكام السيطره على
ثلاث منافذ اما الحميداويه شكرا جزيلا لك
على كل هذه التفاصيل شكرا